each year tens of thousands of children
many under the age of 10 are trafficked
for sex and unfortunately Las Vegas is a
hub for this industry while programs
exist to help teenagers who are sold for
sex there are few resources for younger
victims but a newly formed non-profit
called Arc or Agape rescues children has
formed in Las Vegas and is holding its
first fundraising event tomorrow their
primary goal to build and operate a
sanctuary for children who are rescued
from sex Rings arc's founder says more
than half of the kids who are trafficked
come from the foster care system or
child protective agencies which means
returning them to the system where their
families may not be an option
well you know George the ones that I I'm
looking at are the children
unfortunately that are sold into
trafficking by their families or the
families hand them over to
coyotes or traffickers and you know that
have no place to go these children that
have no place to go so this would be
kind of like a sanctuary it is kind of a
sanctuary and that first Sanctuary would
be built in Las Vegas but Arc hopes to
someday expand Nationwide the fundraiser
is tomorrow from 4 to 6 p.m at setabello
Restaurant on West Sahara